festival de cannes maintenant avec la
projection très attendue du dernier film
des frères dardenne aujourd'hui ils sont
deux fois palme d'or à cannes avec
rosetta en 99 et l'enfant en 2005
la journée aura également été marquée
par la présentation du film d'augustin
legrand le porte-parole des enfants de
don quichotte dominique poncet la thalie
berthier
les réalisateurs faisant un bisou à la
comédienne qui porte leur film cette
image craquante très inhabituelles comme
une séance photo à cannes ce sont les
frères dardenne qui ont offert ce matin
aux télévisions du monde entier pas
blasé donc ces réalisateurs belges
déjà possesseur de deux palmes d'or il
dit et qui entraient en lice ce matin
pour une troisième récompense avec le
silence de lorna reportons président
parce que rien si après le mariage si
elle était enceinte
une tragédie contemporaine ou sur les
trafics parfois mortelles organisée
autour des mariages blancs tarifs avant
toi
on avait des ingrédients autour de la
culpabilité et autour de l'ordre de la
possibilité de sauver un homme ne pas
sauver dans leur nouvel opus on retrouve
là tout entier le style des frères
dardenne à la fois sombre et radicale
distancié et émotionnel ce week-end rit
danse avec elle qu'on les oies sauvages
l'émotion elle devrait également
submergé ceux qui découvriront ce soir
sur la croisette
ce documentaire produit par mathieu
kassovitz sur l'action des enfants de
don quichotte
l'association créée en décembre 2010 par
le comédien augustin legrand pour venir
en aide aux sans abri de paris
pour ce documentaire augustin legrand
s'est fait réalisateur nous en comptons
continuer à monter les marches
quelque part c'est que c'est vraiment un
prolongement de films prolongement de
l'action vous comprenez aussi c'est que
ce film ça sera un outil de lutte
pacifique mais un vrai outil en donnant
la priorité aux gens qui sont révoltés
qui est insupportable et va te dire mon
stop émotion sur les écrans mais dans
les rues aussi aujourd'hui avec cette
marche cuménique en faveur des victimes
du cyclone en birmanie en tête de
cortège
quatre moines bouddhistes bien en main
et la comédienne jane birkin pour être
effectués offert fait un chacal
et pour refermer cette chronique
ce dernier moment de pure émotion offert
à notre caméra par monica bellucci